les violences qui se multiplient
vont-elles embrasé israël ce soir dans
le 19 20
une interview exclusive du premier
ministre israélien yitzhak shamir
michel rocard réitère son appel au
consensus lors du débat sur
l'immigration à l'assemblée nationale
russell a tranché la régie devra
rembourser 6 milliards de francs sous
les yeux suivent et à lui avait versé
tomber sa dette
non soir 48 heures après l'attentât de
rishon-le-zion la situation en israël et
dans les territoires occupés est si
préoccupante que nous avons décidé de
réaliser une grande partie de ce journal
en direct de jérusalem nous ferons le
point sur la situation
grâce aux reportages de nos envoyés
spéciaux mais ce soir la décision d'un
homme va peser très lourd dans l'avenir
de ce conflit cet homme c'est le premier
ministre israélien il axera mire paul
amar la rencontrer cet après midi peu la
marque que nous rejoignons tout de suite
à jérusalem
cette édition spéciale que nous avons
voulu réaliser de jérusalem à cause de
la gravité des événements vous laissera
peut-être une drôle d'impression et vous
éprouverez ce que nous avons éprouvé
aujourd'hui un sentiment mêlé
d'inquiétude et d'espoir d'inquiétude
parce que le face à face entre
israéliens et palestiniens a tourné
quelques fois au tragique
nous le verrons d'espoir même si le move
surprend parce que certains leaders
politiques prendront peut-être
conscience de l'impasse dans laquelle il
se trouve et de la nécessité urgente
d'en sortir
c'est le sens l'entretien exclusif que
le premier ministre israélien itzhak
shamir a bien voulu accorder au 19 20
mai avant de l'écouter
revenons sur la journée d'aujourd'hui
avec francine raymond jamais la guerre
des pierres n'avait eu une telle ampleur
sauf aux premiers jours du soulèvement
palestinien en décembre 87 malgré le
couvre-feu générale imposée dans les
territoires occupés à un million
palestiniens partout des affrontements à
jérusalem est où d'importantes forces de
l'ordre ont été déployés cet après midi
plusieurs manifestations palestiniennes
ont été dispersés à coups de gaz
lacrymogènes la deuxième journée de
grève générale décrétée en signe de
deuil a été massivement suivie dans tous
les territoires occupés c'est à gaza que
la tension est la plus vive
un palestinien a été tué aujourd'hui par
les tirs des soldats israéliens s'ils
186e victimes palestiniennes en deux ans
et demi de guerre des pierres mais
surtout l'intifada se répondent à
l'extérieur des territoires à nazareth
la plus grande ville arabe israélienne
cette nuance eu lieu de violents
affrontements entre jeunes arabes et
forces de sécurité
barricades attaques de bâtiments publics
incidents qui se sont soldés par
l'arrestation de 40 arabe de nationalité
israélienne
au moment où le mur de berlin tombe au
moment où les peuples d'europe de l'est
se retrouvent sur les mêmes valeurs
le proche orient seraient ils condamnés
par une sorte de malédiction à subir une
guerre éternelle à cette question
certains leaders ici veulent répondre
non c'est le cas du trac shamir qui
s'était pourtant distingué jusqu'ici par
sa fermeté
mais le premier ministre a tenu
aujourd'hui a insisté sur la nécessité
de négociations directes avec les
palestiniens
il l'a dit au 19 20 après avoir condamné
fermement le massacre commis par le
jeune israélien
écoutons le jeu vous l'amour déçu compte
dans convainc ses cris on accepte en
train dé fait le pari d'un autre société
ça n'arrive jamais c'est un acte qui a
considérablement troubler la société
civile israélienne
est-ce qu'il ne traduit pas dans sa
folie évidemment un certain malaise au
sein du peuple israélien
en ce moment de tout partout c'est un
cas totalement isolé vous êtes conscient
de l'image cas l'état d'israël dans le
monde aujourd'hui
ce avec la communication de la mollesse
avons c'est malin ça bon ne savons que
l'image qu'on a
en dehors d'un autre pays mais ne
reflètent pas la réalité
pour montrer votre votre bonne volonté
votre volonté de paix pourquoi ne pas
prendre une initiative même
spectaculaire et oui nous avons lancé
l'initiative des pelles ya un an nous
avons proposé au monde arabe akra des
négociations y compris de la médiation
avec les états arabes et le sahara price
rien est ce que cette initiative passe
par des élections libres en cisjordanie
à gaza sur sa jv élections savoir
seulement avec les ara palestine alors
c'est nous que nous avons proposé cette
possibilité des élections afin que les
palestiniens
ellis les représentants pour négocier
avec nous mais il s'agit pas d'aider
proclamer un état il en conflit et il
s'agit du territoire qui est à notre
avis appartient à nous c'est une partie
de notre héritage vous voulez dire que
la cisjordanie et gaza appartiennent ils
sont partis du pays d'israël
c'est notre croyance et nous croyons que
notre foi les price tandis que ça
appartiennent et il faut négocier parce
que si vous voulez résoudre une telle
question
il ya des voix ont bien mené une guerre
on vient vous négociez alors une fois
les boursiers nous avons proposé entre à
des négociations avec les palestiniens
avec les états arabes
alors il faut réaliser ses plans
il faut faire de ses pleins et réalité
alors vous dites vous même monsieur le
premier ministre nous sommes prêts nous
serons prêts à négocier avec les
représentants élus par les citoyens
palestiniens v6 est situé à ses
électeurs palestiniens est listé
représentant proche de noël pèse
quelques fait bouffer tête
il faut prendre des ris mais tout
d'abord il faut élire ses représentants
je vais plus loin j'anticipe ils élisent
leurs représentants proches de l'ump
un beau jour
vous pourriez être assis à la même table
car à face je ne crois pas qu'ils arafat
participera dans une telle négociation
parce qu'il ne courra pas il n'accepte
pas notre plan il veut tout de suite
avoir un état palestinien
il veut il vécut mousse et ben aknoun
immédiatement tout ce territoire la
question
pas question autrement dit vous proposez
vous votre plan de temps dans un premier
temps l'autonomie et pourquoi pas plus
tard
plus tard la constitution d'un état d'un
pays comme on voudra qui pourrait être
palestinien sao faut revoir parce que
après cette période telle autonomie
il faudrait négocier à négocier nous
avec les partenaires sur l'avenir sur le
statut permanent de ces territoires
donc malgré la violence malgré
l'intifada vous restez quand même
profondément optimiste vous croyez qu'un
jour un jour il pourra y avoir la paix
sur cette terre je suis sûr je veux la
guerre n'est jamais terme l espoir de
paix quand tout s'enflamme cela peut
paraître paradoxal mais il arrive
souvent que les hommes politiques se
ressaisisse quand le point de non retour
semble être atteint on attend maintenant
la réponse de yasser arafat à la
proposition d itzhak shamir
merci paul en france c'est le débat sur
l'immigration qui fait la une de
l'actualité les députés se sont
retrouvés en milieu d'après midi à
l'assemblée nationale de ce débat
sortira la décision de l'opposition de
participer ou non à la table ronde sur
l'immigration à matignon michel rocard a
joué l'ouverture mais l'opposition se
fait apparemment tirer l'oreille
daniel sportiello a suivi les débats à
l'assemblée nationale
s'il vient avec des propositions
précises la discussion sinon il fera des
parents
michel rocard savait que son discours
servirait de test et que ses réponses
conditionnerait la participation du rpr
et de l'udf à la prochaine table ronde
de matignon aussi en at il appelé à la
responsabilité des partis républicains
leur demandons de créer ensemble les
conditions d'une bataille contre
l'extrême droite
et pour preuve de sa bonne volonté le
premier ministre a affirmé qu'il
n'évoquera pas plus demain qu'hier le
droit de vote aux immigrés mais
attention surenchère a toutefois averti
michel rocard majorité s'est montrée
prête courageusement à faire une partie
du chemin mais de grâce que l'on ne
demande pas la majorité comme gage de sa
bénévolence de commencer par s'aligner
en point sur les positions de
l'opposition et je ne crois pas
raisonnable l'attitude consistant à
inventer chaque jour de nouveaux
préalable des nouveaux préalable comme
la récente du code de la nationalité
réclamée par le rpr michel rocard la
trouve très discutable et secondaire du
coup le rpr a fait la fine bouche à la
proposition de charte minimal de
matignon la volonté d'intégration elle
existe et elle ne suffit pas ce dont la
france a besoin monsieur le premier
ministre ce n'est pas d'une charte
minimale c'est d'une politique globale
de l'immigration et la méthode de
concertation rocard ne passe pas
l'opposition n'a pas totalement fermé la
porte
dans la soirée le premier ministre est
attendu par les parlementaires pour un
nouvel examen de passage non michel
levert vous êtes en direct de
l'assemblée nationale sur le dossier de
l'immigration
le consensus le consensus pardon semble
très difficile à atteindre
la comparaison peut paraître un peu
hardie sur un sujet aussi grave mais on
a le même sentiment que lorsqu'on
assiste à un match de football où les
partenaires hésitent à se livrer à faire
le jeu alors bien sûr michel rocard a
apporté des précisions ou l'avait
souligné par exemple sur le vote des
immigrés mais pour l'essentiel il s'est
surtout appliqué à définir une méthode
une philosophie
pour essayer d'aboutir à cette charte
minimale avec l'opposition alors cette
opposition trouve naturellement que tout
cela est parfaitement insuffisant elle
fait plutôt monter les enchères et
veulent des réponses précises mais dans
le même temps elle prend bien garde de
ne prononcer aucun propos irrémédiable
comme si elle ne voulait pas prendre la
responsabilité de briser ce fragile
consensus qui s'était établi à près
carpentras alors ce sentiment est aussi
renforcée par le fait qu'on est qu'à la
fin de la première mi temps michel
rocard répondre à tout à l'heure aux
orateurs sans doute un peu après minuit
et c'est à ce moment là que se jouera le
sort de la table ronde c'est en deuxième
mi temps que le match peut basculer
merci michel politique toujours jean
marie le pen a annoncé cet après midi
son intention d'engager une procédure
judiciaire à l'encontre de la
municipalité de dinars cette dernière
avait refusé de lui louer le palais des
congrès de la ville pour les prochaines
universités d'été du front national
le débat sur l'immigration en
intéressera sûrement pas le maire
divers-droite de rose est une petite
commune des yvelines jean leroy en effet
déjà arrêté sa position il ne veut pas
entendre parler de métissage il l'a fait
savoir très clairement en refusant
d'apposer dans sa mairie la fiche de la
quinzaine de l'enseignement public
motif les enfants dessiner sur cette
affiche ne sont pas je cite à 100% blanc
reportage sur place jean jacques mazier
et gérard boisseau des 350 habitants de
rosé très peu aujourd'hui était dehors
portes fermées volets clos à croire que
toute la population se cachait et se
refusait à échanger le moindre propos
avec la presse dans l'école aucun bruit
et d'ailleurs les récréations ont été
supprimés pour la journée
quant à l'entrée de la mairie elle était
interdite à certaines espèces vivantes
aujourd'hui la mairie est fermée aux
journalistes au reporter et en chien cet
avertissement est de la même veine que
la lettre envoyée à la fédération de
l'enseignement
le maire jean leroy explique qu'ils
refusent l'affichage public de ce dessin
de peyo autorisé et encouragé par le
ministre de l'éducation il estime qu'il
représente ce qu'il ne veux jamais voir
dans son école le métissage scolaire
dit-il avec 25% de [ __ ] 25% des
arabisants urban et 25% de jaune safrané
et deux malheureux petits blancs
minoritaire des propos extrêmement
graves dont apparemment son conseil
municipal n'assume pas la paternité
n'est pas au courant
l'ami personnes au courant
moi j'étais passionné depuis hier matin
et j'ai pas sans qu est ce que vous
allez faire vous allez réagir vous
allait démissionner ça me travaille mais
mais quelques parents d'élèves que nous
avons pu rencontrer se disent tous
scandalisés par cette lettre du maire et
la ligue de l'enseignement s'apprête à
engager des poursuites à givors le
racisme a franchi vendredi les portes
d'une salle de classe en l'absence de
leurs professeurs les élèves ont en
effet recouvert les murs de leur classe
avec des graffitis racistes et
antisémites
contre toute attente c'est le professeur
qui a été sanctionné il a été suspendu
aujourd'hui un comité de soutien s'est
mis en place ce reportage
fr3 lyon suspension du professeur
boissin cardinal sont graves a été
décidé de façon très rapide par le
rectorat et à l'unanimité par le conseil
d'administration de l'établissement
en l'état actuel de l'enquêté rien ne
prouve que le prof d'histoire et de
français soit directement à l'origine
des graffitis racistes et antisémites
inscrit dans sa classe mais on lui
reproche de ne pas avoir su maintenir la
discipline ce n'est pas parce qu'il
l'avait le chahut dans ces classes qui
qu'il a été suspendu c'est parce que au
fond de sa classe à un moment donné le
chalut a débordé et a fait que ces murs
ont été souillés d'inscription la
publicité donnée autour de cette affaire
de la part de l'administration est peu
ordinaire
elle est encore moins ordinaire de la
part du proviseur de l'établissement qui
a étouffé pour que de choses pendant
l'année il a étoffé la montée de la
violence sur les personnes et les biens
le vandalisme il a étouffé et tout fait
jusqu'à ce que la situation devienne si
respirable suspendu jusqu'à nouvel ordre
ludwig wes un cardinal touche sans
traitement en attendant les
prolongements de cette affaire
compliquée le chapitre économique
maintenant avec une mauvaise nouvelle le
chiffre du comex du commerce extérieur
français pour le mois d'avril est
inquiétant ils s'élèvent à plus de 4
milliards de francs 4,3 111 milliards
très exactement
pour les quatre premiers mois de l'année
le déficit a donc atteint 11 21
milliards de francs l'année dernière
pour la même période il est
de plus de 13 milliards de francs 6
milliards de francs c'est le prix d'un
compromis le compromis passé ce matin à
bruxelles entre le gouvernement français
et la commission européenne
renault devra donc rembourser la moitié
de ce que la firme doit pas l'état soit
6 milliards de francs
explications marie-hélène tichoux
bérégovoy comme michel rocard était
monté au créneau le gouvernement
français avait montré les dents le vice
président de la commission de bruxelles
leon brittan aussi ce matin ils ont
passé un compromis et ils sont soulagés
ce qui me soulage c'est que ce que nous
ayons signé la paix ça qui me soulage et
dans des conditions qui me passent forte
durable
je pense qu'il fallait éviter que
renault comme nous on est à subir une
ponction qui aurait qui ont entravé son
essor c'est vraiment pas le cas trois
milliards et demi c'est quand même assez
loin de tous milliards et puis alors
c'est un compromis politique et au sens
le plus lourd du terme dans la mesure où
maintenant renault devient une société
comme les autres donc donc dans la
commission n'aura plus à s'occuper
renault doit rembourser immédiatement
trois milliards et demi de francs à
l'état la direction de la régie l'avait
prévu et avait mis de côté plus de 2
milliards en provisions exceptionnelles
dans son bilan 89
l'addition est un peu plus lourde mais
pas excessive le reste de la somme
exigée par bruxelles soit deux milliards
et demi sera inscrite comme tête à long
terme sur le cahier des comptes de
renault
ce compromis a permis d'éviter la crise
entre paris et bruxelles dans six mois
l'état français et volvo pourront
procéder à une augmentation de capital
celle-ci effacera de fête l'amande 3
milliards et demi infligée par bruxelles
le ciel décidément perdu la tête après
une période de sécheresse très
inquiétante des orages se sont abattues
la nuit dernière sur l'ouest de la
france avec une rare violence rivière en
crue inondation
un homme a même été emportés dans un
torrent de pluie il est mort noyé
reportage fr3 nantes yves rétifs c'est
au coeur du vignoble du pays nantais à
clisson que sont tombés plus de 80
millimètres d'eau en une heure trente
seulement cette exceptionnelle pour la
région des torrents de boue ont alors
tout balayer danse est content
et maloney à gorge un homme de 54 ans
qui voulait soulever une plaque d'égout
a été aspirés sous les yeux de son
épouse
son corps a été retrouvé mardi matin
dans un ruisseau à un kilomètre du lieu
de sa disparition
les dégâts sont catastrophiques pour
quelques maisons beaucoup de caves et un
certain nombre d'équipements de voirie
une dizaine de groupes de
sapeurs-pompiers venus de trente
kilomètres à la ronde
de nantes à aigrefeuille en vendée ont
rapidement effectué 120 interventions
dans les zones les plus urgents on peut
dire que les dégâts importants se
situent dans cette wii maison à peu près
qui ont vu pour certaines l'eau arrivait
presque jusqu'au premier étage et pour
d'autres bons va dégât des eaux servant
dans les sous-sols l'on voit ça c'est
pas eux mais c'est habituel mais c'est
presqu'aussi des murs quelques toitures
se sont effondrés sous la violence des
orages semblables à des précipitations
tropicale dès mardi matin les autorités
ont réuni à l'état major de crise à la
mairie de clisson pour arrêter les
premières mesures en faveur des
sinistrés
on a bien du mal à le croire en voyant
ces images mais c'est la sécheresse qui
préoccupe qui préoccupe le plus les
agriculteurs et leurs syndicats
le président la fnsea raymond lacombe en
effet annoncé aujourd'hui la mise en
place d'une cellule de crise au sein de
la fédération fnsea craint en effet que
les efforts des agriculteurs pour
réduire leur consommation d'eau ne se
retourne contre raymond lacombe
interrogé par véronique d'aurel vous
savez quel sur les réserves au bourrelet
sont très basses les habitudes de leurs
responsabilités ils ont changé en
particulier de production au lieu de
faire autant mais ils ont fait du
tournesol
mais pour cela il ya les conséquences
négatives à bruxelles car chaque fois
qu'on le dépasse un volume de production
sol par exemple il ya une baisse des
prix c'est insupportable dont nous avons
demandé aux mises l'agriculture de
négocier à bruxelles
la non application de cette mesure ou
que les agriculteurs aient finalement
brique au rex à la sortie sinon il subit
à la fois de calamités la sécheresse
plus une baisse insupportable et plus
j'espère les commotions entendu le
rififi à la mérite de vierzon voici tout
de suite les autres faits marquants de
l'actualité en france grâce aux images
de nos stations régionales commentaire
hervé dino
bastion communiste depuis 31 ans vire
vent est passé entre les mains du
socialiste jean rousseau le maire pc
fernand micouraud démissionnaire avait
proposé comme successeur un de ses
adjoints communiste mais le ps en
s'alliant à des membres du conseil sans
étiquette a obtenu la majorité des élus
communistes ont immédiatement
démissionné ce qui entraînera une
nouvelle élection municipale le 17 juin
jean rousseau a été désavoué par les
instances nationales du ps
marseille se dépeuple au cours des huit
dernières années la seconde ville de
france a perdu cent mille habitants au
profit de sa périphérie et ne compte
plus que huit cent mille personnes les
marseillais ont en fait suivi les
entreprises qui ont quitté le centre
ville en simple enterrant banlieue tout
nouveau tout beau voilà le dernier char
de l'armée française puissant facile à
manoeuvrer et bourré d'électronique le
char leclerc est doté d'un canon qui
tire deux obus en 4 secondes avec une
précision de 3000 m la première
livraison de ce juge ou qui coûte
environ 29 millions de francs est prévu
fin 91 nouveau départ dans l' enquête
sur le pilote du off shore qui le 17 ou
81,80 y va percuter plusieurs baigneurs
tuant un jeune homme de 22 ans avant de
prendre la fuite depuis les faits c'est
la première fois que le juge
d'instruction entend les principaux
témoins de l'accident
une fois deux fois sous réserve de
soumission et voilà adjugé pour 1
million 700 mille francs le gym note un
sous marin qui depuis 24 ans servi
loyalement la royale il est bien mal
récompensée puisque l'acquéreur un
industriel brestois l'a racheté au prix
de la ferraille
il a maintenant un mois pour le découper
en morceaux la télé carte avait déjà
étonné par son immense succès commercial
la voici officiellement reconnu par les
sages de la coupole le mot télécartes
est en effet entrée aujourd'hui au
dictionnaire de l'académie française
une entrée en grande pompe scellé par
une cérémonie officielle en présence du
ministre des postes des
télécommunications et de l'espace
reportage jean jacques peyraud plus de
100 millions de télés cartes vendues en
cinq ans de toutes les couleurs illustré
par des dizaines d'artistes et par 350
annonceurs publicitaires
en cinq ans elle est devenue non
seulement un objet d' usage quotidien
mais aussi un objet de collection qui se
revend à prix d'or bref un must à sa
naissance pourtant lorsqu'elle était
modestement rayer le bleu comme un
pyjama france télécom trembler le public
elle est il l'adopté la carte à puce le
set virait telle réponse éclatante
aujourd'hui 77 % des usagers la préfère
aux pièces de monnaie
les ptt également et pour cause plus de
pièces dans les cabines donc moins de
vandales le nombre des publiphones
dégradé et dix fois moindre qu'en 85
seul risque pour l'usagé qu'on la lui
dérobe
attention aux collectionneurs fous ans
pensait le coach néo-zélandais style
lagarde qui a remporté cet après midi à
southampton la course autour du monde à
la voile en équipage à peter blake le
barreur à accomplir le grand chelem en
remportant toutes les étapes de la
whitbread le départ de la course avait
été donnée
2 septembre dernier oui tout de suite
ses superbes images d'arrivée de
steinegger 2 c'était cet après midi à
southampton
elle est belle elle est même splendide
mais elle est chère même prêche une
ferrari de compétition de 1962 a été
vendu hier soir à monte-carlo près de 60
millions de francs la berlinetta devient
ainsi la voiture la plus chère du monde
rémy gullit chez lui en rêve encore
ferrari a un nom des légendes servi par
les plus grands pilotes du monde
une couleur que même les néophytes
reconnaissent comme celle de la victoire
et de la classe rien d'étonnant alors à
ce que l'une d'entre elles la plus
titrée sans doute se soit fait enlevé
hier soir à prix d'or à monter car 60
millions de francs pour cette berlinette
250 gto symbole d'une voiture imbattable
au début des années 60 sur tous les
circuits
les 250 gt ont marqué l'histoire un
patrimoine qu'enzo ferrari le
commendatore est disparu il ya deux ans
a toujours jalousement cultiver on
n'achète pas en fait le cheval cabré du
célèbre ingénieur et à l'exemple des f40
dernière née de la famille elles sont
déjà entrés dans la légende avant même
que quelques milliardaires ne les
apprivoise derrière les cris de leurs
résidences privées voient la fin de
cette édition les programmes de la 3 ce
soir avec à 20 heures la classe à 20h30
une édition spéciale de la marche du
siècle de jean marie cavada le nuremberg
à carpentras avec notamment invité elie
wiesel ou le rabbin sitruk
prochain rendez vous avec la formation
c'est à 22h15 soit fois représenté par
marc hautement à donner vos voix
oui